hey guys Pete Bevers here and today
we're going to look at a gameplay
preview for the next installment in the
Pet Rescue saga series and this one is
gonna be called pet rescue Patrol saga I
apologize I have a bit of a cold right
now it's in soft-launched and it's still
called senior while leads rescue clicker
but I noticed they uploaded a new
version this past week in the actual apk
name is that rescue Patrol and I've also
seen some some graphics that they were
working on that they were taking votes
about that include the word Patrol so
it's definitely going to be pet rescue
Patrol saga before it's all said and
done so if you love Pet Rescue saga
you'll definitely like this game right
from the beginning same mechanics only
updated and a lot less chunky same kind
of characters you know you're still
rescuing the pets are still working with
friends to make your way through the map
and advance through the levels I'm gonna
play one real quick and we'll talk about
some of the differences and then I'll go
back and show you some new things
they're really upping the social aspect
of it I think so this is level 14 Cairo
is the episode in the original version
they just sort of went 1 through 10 for
the different cities now they're in
Normal
numerical order like other games so
that's that's a cool little change you
can see we have our goal is to rescue at
least 6 pets earn at least one star but
we can see how many we need to get to
get the three star which would be 12 so
hit the play button and get a look at
the board this level has a couple
different
things it's got ice and it's got the
directional arrows which show that we
have to move these Pat's who are sitting
on these shelves to the middle before we
can get them to the bottom and that's
the basic gist if you weren't a big pet
rescue fan you might forget if you
haven't been playing it but the basic
gist is it's a it's a collapsing style
match three similar to like diamond
digger I guess is one of the newer ones
that they have but you you can match
three of the same or two of the same
actually or more of any color and it
will remove that color and the board and
the remaining squares will collapse and
so you know we want to bring them to the
bottom so one of the things that happens
here as you can see these are lit up and
that's called a color wave and you can
see that if we match these mutts down
here even though these red ones aren't
collect connected directly will get the
ice off of those as well and you see the
GUP of the color wave graphic right
there so we're bringing our pets down
we'll save this one right here I really
like that the the life rat or life saver
thing that comes in I think that's a
cool little thing we could save him him
or her I guess I should say and that's
you know that's basically what we've got
to do is we just collapse the bricks and
the pets fall down to the bottom now
we're saying about how the the arrows
show you that you have to move them over
the way you do that is you make a match
next to them and then they'll slide now
there aren't any other purple ones down
here for what I'm gonna do is clear the
ice first and then move them and he'll
fall right down to the bottom and here
we can see our colorway wave we'll set
that one
so we had up at the top you see we have
26 moves we have for pets rescued and if
we get two more then we'll have our one
star and the level D complete this whole
this colorway will bring em across their
egos and we thought up the meter so now
we can use our anchor and the way this
works is you click on the captain down
here and we have an anchor you can move
it right or you move it left anywhere on
the board and let me hit the anchor
button and it'll drop it and will clear
out a row there's not really any reason
to use it right here so I'll wait but
it's ready to go when you see this glow
around it and he's waving to you so
you'll know a lot of times you'll just
use it right away but other times you
know like right here like I said there
wasn't really much I'll just go ahead
and do it here because it'll move him to
the bottom but if you pick any row click
on the things you know it's active
because the pets have their helmets on
and there you go it clears the row all
the way to the bar sort of like a rocket
from Pat rescue but it works from the
top to the bottom instead of the other
way so cool feature like I said that the
graphics really a lot a lot smoother you
can see how everything just sort of has
a great finished look to it that I think
you know the early early version of Pet
Rescue came out but you know it's one of
the first releases that was big for King
so they learned a lot and the mechanics
and they're they have better game
engines now and I think that that'll be
one thing but I we have our full I could
keep going for 16 more moves but I'm
going to show you some other things
instead but one of the things that
I don't think pet original was a bad
game but I think maybe the players who
are playing you know the the newer games
it might seem a little outdated so
that's what's actually really cool about
this is that it has that up-to-date look
and it really showcases what an awesome
excuse me what an awesome awesomely fun
you know game type the collapsing style
can be so I think this will definitely
be really popular so okay now I'm gonna
look at the map here and you can see we
have so couple different things going on
we have a lifesaver with one of our
neighbors with a life saver on level
seven level seven is the only one in the
first row that I didn't get three stars
on so if we look at look at the opening
screen we can see that one of our
friends named Magda has sent us help and
that's a plus five moves so if I you
don't have to select it or anything if I
play you can see that
five extra moves and they're added to my
total at the beginning of the level
so I'm not gonna play this one there's
not much else in there to see but that's
what the low that's what the little
lifesaver oh man that means you can see
in our star count at the top we have 38
yellow stars those are the stars over
here and from the levels and I was
actually through the whole game before
but when they repackaged it even though
I connected my account as you can see it
I had to start from the beginning so I
haven't played all the way through yet
but one of the the blue stuff this
yellow sort of has the blue stars are
from when we help other people as you
can see on here on the side it says
level 2 and level 2 has this rain and a
little icon with one of our friends and
when we click on this it says you know
this player needs to be it seems to be
in the need of help so you don't see the
rain like I said in the water line so
when we go in here this is called a hose
you think
think of what it was called it's like
hold on I'm gonna pause this and look
because I just made a video of this
earlier okay yeah so it's called a flash
flood and what happens is the board gets
turned upside down basically sort of
like soda and candy crush soda it's
filled with water the don't worry about
the pets they're in a bubble and they
have their goggles on so they can see
just fine but um we have to bring them
to the top instead of the other way
around so when I make a match outside of
the water not much happens but when I
make a match inside the water you can
see they rise towards the top in their
bubbles so we just like I said do pretty
much the same thing that we had had done
it's just reverse gravity so its goal
gives you a you know a different
different thing to think about and once
we get that to the very top he gets
picked up by the lifesaver and all as
well so yeah we just keep bringing them
up and what's funny I will just look at
this real quick the anchor does the
exact same thing except for when you
clear a row here the pet will move to
the top instead of cool and what's cool
about this and what I think it's nice
about this when you're waiting for
levels you know you can go back and you
can help your friends out
it's hard to tell and in the early
stages because a lot of people aren't
playing and things like that but what I
tend to believe is that you know if
you're stuck in a really hard level for
a lot for a little while it'll be sort
of like it used to be and in pepper
panic where or candy crush the original
candy crush that if you're stuck there
for a while you will get your friends
will get the opportunity to send you
extra moves and so it would be the same
thing here like if you're stuck on you
know a really tough level higher on the
map and you can't get past it your
friends will see this little icon on the
side and they'll be able to go and
replay a level maybe that they've
already beaten and they'll be able to
send you you know five extra moves for
that level so that that's a cool thing
that was you know that's been popular in
other games but they sort of moved away
from it I can't think of any other
titles they've used it on since pepper
panic but I you know I could be wrong so
you know the big idea the big question
that everybody wants to know is when
will it be out I think it'll be awhile
you know Farm hero super saga has moved
together you know moved along a lot
faster in the soft launch so I think
that it's all that's been that's going
to be coming out first and then that's
supposed to be around April sometimes so
you know this might be a summer release
I guess but um you know it's cool I'm
excited you know there's only so many
games I can play and you know it's kind
of frustrating sometimes but this one I
really like you know I think it's it you
know it's a different it's not a swipe
game so you know it's fun to figure out
the strategy and you know keep going
so we'll see what when it happens
obviously on our page Pet Rescue Pet
Rescue Patrol saga tips we'll we'll keep
you updated how things come along and
you know like I said I
you know could pause I could be wrong
I've been wrong about things before but
you know we'll see but I think it would
probably be a summertime thing so we'll
see what happens
check it out if you're in the soft
launch region you know if you have any
questions leave comments below like my
like my channel or like this video if
I'm helpful so other people can find out
about this game too and subscribe to my
channel to keep up to date with all the
you know all the latest release gameplay
videos all the best level videos for the
popular games that you like and we'll
talk to you soon yeah